a lot of people may not remember New
Year's Eve since discount champagne and
2016 rage don't mix but stuff happened
Jenny McCarthy was cold
people in Times Square didn't pee for
like 12 hours Mariah Carey performed or
rather wandered around stage mumbling
instead of lip-synching because of
technical issues and so forth
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
am i higher was that flawless that one
is dedicated to a job as the backup
dancers you can almost hear and what the
feathers going keep it together Kevin
this is why you went to Juilliard I
think they should have just cut away and
and let this lawnmower fill in
[Music]
I'll have what the lawnmower is
happening after Mariah's live
nationally-televised debacle me without
the dick jokes Ryan Seacrest handled
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody knows and how about those
lyrics that everyone knows except for my
that is some next-level expert level
damage control on the fly so comedians
how else could Ryan Seacrest's have
given her performance a positive spin
Jonah ray
you gotta hand it to Mariah she's
probably not a racist duck she could
shoot somebody in the middle of the
street and everyone would still vote for
her
[Applause]